[Musique]
des statistiques des prime des deuxièmes
parties de soirée il est sa matière
camille qu'avec habitat tu fais ta vie
ta vie on arrête ta biolay emmanuelle
macro est avec nous merci manuellement
vous allez bien c'est bien passé sur tf1
alors ça c'est bien passé vous n'avez
pas regardé aux puces et en direct en
face au japon on m'avait dit que vous
aviez mis toutes les missions sur le
débat que j'étais en train de faire sur
tf1 j'avais un petit écran je ne voulais
pas je crois oui je voudrais vous dire
aujourd'hui c'est la millième de tpm
paix et j'avais un défi c'est que vous
ne souhaitiez pas d'anniversaire avant
bien sûr le 7 mai et cette belle
échéance
voilà sp1 alors je vais vous dire trois
choses un oiseau qui veut prendre le
contrôle de l'émission bon dans trois
choses la première je ne vous félicite
pas parce que si vous êtes à la millième
c'est que vous n'avez pas regardé sur
tf1 donc
donc je prends ma perte tant pis pour
nous regardez le en replay j'ai essayé
de dire des choses intelligentes et de
vos combats deuxième chose
bon anniversaire bonne millièmes comme
président pour la 1500e ça serait
parfait
ce serait pas mal je sais je sais pas si
on va y arriver mais bon moi je ferai
tout pour d'ici le 7 mai et la troisième
je vous le dis allez voter le 7 mai pour
qui que ce soit évidemment moi je vais
plutôt vous dire d'aller voter pour moi
je vais être honnête mais c'est pas le
lieu ni mais aller voter quoi qu'il en
soit aller voter c'est très important
jeunes moins jeunes aller voter il ya
des gens qui se sont battus pour avoir
ce droit à les exprimer vos opinions
sinon vous décidé de laisser la place
aux autres donc c'est pas vous qui
déciderez l'avenir de la france dans les
cinq prochaines années donc aller voter
et bon anniversaire
merci beaucoup emmanuel macron merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup emmanuel macron
elle et merci merci beaucoup vraiment et
on a réussi le défi merci à eux
merci à tous merci à tf1 merci beaucoup
enchantée merci beaucoup saluent le gars
et merci à tf1 et merci à emmanuel
macron le défi relevé et merci et merci
et j'aimerais aller voter le 7 mai les
chéris cette importante qui racontera
votez pour qui vous voulez aller voter
tati sur moi je regarde pas tout c'est
énorme ce qui s'est passé l'issue rip et
merci à vous merci merci le shérif merci
beaucoup merci mon caddie